2022 what a year let's have a look at
some of the charts that defined it
starting with perhaps the most striking
one of all this is inflation the
Consumer Price Index CPI this is the
annual rate basically prices going up
and have a look in October it got up to
11.1 percent that was the highest that
we've seen since going all the way back
to
1981 and the funny thing is when that
rises you get all sorts of other things
going on in the economy as well let me
put a line for strikes on top of it
we're just superimposing a different
line different axis but look at how
similar the shapes are when inflation's
low you don't get as many strikes when
inflation's high you do tend to get more
strikes and that's exactly what we are
you know experiencing at the moment and
if past is prologue that's also going to
push that red line up even further so
more strikes in the future now what is
it that's driving up prices where it's a
lot of things but above all it's this
gas prices wholesale gas prices and just
look at how low they were through 2007
2008 going all the way through till
about 2021 so just before the event of
Ukraine it got up really sharp and you
can see on the 26th of August in 2022
that is a record the highest ever uh
five pounds 50 thermos some people think
it's going to stay high for a long time
longer even than the government expects
so important thing uh there of course
the consequence of all of this is it
goes into our pockets doesn't it real
household disposable income is a really
good measure of just whether we're
getting better or for worse off so
anything above the line is getting
better off growth and I think below the
line is the opposite and have a look at
what happened in 2022 look at the bars
that come up here look the biggest fall
on record you know that is why we're all
feeling a little bit more a little bit
worse off at the moment and that is
expected to continue in the coming years
as well final thing you couldn't really
talk about 2022 could you without
talking about the pound and about the
mini budget
um remember this is the pound against
the dollar anything above anything going
up is the pound getting stronger we're
going back through history 1985 the
plaza record up until recently the
lowest it ever got about one dollar uh
and five you've got black ones this day
that wasn't a good moment for the
government of the Tory government as
well you've got 2016 the EU referendum
look at these big falls in the pound
never really recovered from there
but the nadir the real nadir was at the
mini budget I just thought the days
after the mini budget got to the lowest
level ever since the creation of the
dollar it's recovered since but some
people think it could Plumb those debts
again in the future it just goes to show
so many striking charts from 2022 I'm
sure there will be more in 2023 let's
hope it's more good news rather than bad
news